this is a clip from uh The Leftovers
podcast Hassan and uh Ethan Klein
uh this is a a Twitter account uh it's
just Dan I don't know who runs the
account it seems you know Anonymous but
uh I'm GNA play this clip for you guys
Palestinians and this is going to sound
very radical and possibly very violent
but this is a matter of Law and maybe
even if you agree with this a matter of
morality Palestinians
uh have the the legal ground to
violently seize back their own homes
from the settlers this is a reality and
that is precisely the reason why they
have to exist under endless occupation
in the W you and that's why I say if it
was settlers that would be a lot more
understandable but let's not off skate
okay I understand what you're saying but
this dude just called babies militants
no I understand and there are baby
settlers as well but there are baby
settlers as well there are babies in the
settlements but the babies they killed W
they were not I know okay so no hold on
let me can can we just I'll play that
one more time for you occupation the you
and that's why I say if it was settlers
that would be a lot more understandable
he says Hassan says Palestinians have a
right to violently seize back the land
that was taken by settlers then Ethan
Klein says yes if it was settlers but
this guy's saying babies and Hanan goes
but some of the babies are settlers
basically saying this there is
justification for the killing of babies
uh like this is Hassan perer is pure
audience capture this is what he
represents he says whatever is going to
get favor among the people who are
chatting to him and that that's all it
is MHM he like what what did what the
the left is rather insulting like
they're rather condescending to him too
but this is abject evil well I mean
unquestionably to play Devil's Advocate
we don't know what comes after that so
what I'm what I'm hoping Hassan does is
explain that that wouldn't be justified
therefore the Israeli targeting of
Palestinian babies is also not justified
in light of the October 7th attacks
that's what I'm hoping came after that I
don't know
Shak head like no because look at the
yel professor that settlers are not
civilians yeah I I really I I agreed
agreed agreed if in fact the longer clip
in the full context shows Assan say
there is no excuse ever for killing
babies and I recognize that then okay
for for the sake of just this we will be
very clear in that regard Hassan calling
babies settlers while justifying Hamas
killing settlers is a horrifying thing
in of itself and I hope I hope he's
clarified later on that that's that's he
does not support the killing of babies
and I almost never say this but I feel
for Ethan uh over the the past few weeks
the clips I've been seeing because Ethan
is I would say very moderate especially
for an Israeli about the situation he's
actually donated money to help
Palestinians uh he acknowledges that he
does not support Israeli settlement so
that's not like you know where they're
actually like getting you don't think he
is Ethan Klein was an edgy boy on the
internet who made crud jokes way back
way back in the day you don't think he's
mod on the isra don't I think that he
hitched his wagon to the left because
many so he's not a political guy he
knows nothing of politics he's thrust
into this because Donald Trump and the
culture wars turned politics into pop
culture so now if you're somebody if you
you look at his original YouTube channel
where he did silly jokes it was in Decay
it was falling apart he launches a
podcast Channel and now it's more
conversations he has Jordan Peterson on
his show and they're having a great
conversation why it was in it was it was
in it was trendy it was the thing to do
the intellectual dark web then as things
start splitting more seriously in the
culture War he decides he's going to go
left what does he do he tweets Jordan
Peterson's not a good guy so I'm going
to take the episode Down The Only Reason
Ethan Klein comes out and acts moderate
on Israel is because he's desperately
trying not to get cancelled by the left
so you think he's do you think he's a
Zionist and hiding it no no no no no but
I think he's probably somewhat
pro-israel he outright said Hamas is ly
the left believes that right Hamas
propaganda and historical revisionism
his wife is Israeli and again I'm pretty
sure she was in the IDF she was IDF
veteran is it confirmed though for sure
for sure 100% IDF veteran and so he's
thinking like sure I mean he's he may
not be a Zionist but he's certainly like
yeah Israel like he's pro-israel yeah
he's been there so he comes out and says
I'm going to donate to to to
Palestinians and stuff because his
entire audience is this but that's why I
feel bad for him because he is trying to
I mean in this one regard he is trying
to I guess like be as I don't know
Building Bridges as as much as he can
but they're still not accepting it if
can't help but feel for him in that let
let me just stress there have been many
times in the show where I and I have
been mad at each other and we've we've
gone at it I would not ever sit down
next to a person who says yeah but
babies are settlers I'd be like are you
nuts you're not going to sit right here
and tell me you think killing B I'll
take it up to the edge of that but no
because like in Vietnam seven-year-olds
had grenades and baskets and they'd walk
up to the American Soldier and then
they'd blow them up so they had to start
shooting seveny old but babies are they
don't move they just lay there you take
them captive at the very least lay there
they they lay there and they cry and
Ethan kleene is sitting there actually
having a discussion with this guy and
the fact that the show didn't stop on
the spot when he said that I would have
been like no no no no no tell me right
now you are not saying what you are
saying Ethan's just like well I mean
come on and they go back and forth a
little bit I'm I'm sorry I think Ethan
Klein saw his his waning internet
presence and decided I got to choose a
side I'm going to go with the left
because that's what celebrities are
doing and that's what I get guess we do
because it was not a principle based
decision nor a knowledge based one you
take a look at when Steven Crowder
wanted to have a conversation with Ethan
so what did Ethan do brought in Sam
Cedar and totally pulled a stunt because
he is not a political guy and even says
it then why the is he doing leftovers
anyway well congratulations dude you had
an opportunity to sit with Jordan Peters
and have a conversation with someone who
is very moderate open and understanding
Jordan Peterson's famous interview with
I think it was Jim Jeff where Jeffrey
says do you think the government should
mandate you know that people provide
service he goes no and he goes what
about black people like civil rights and
Jordan Peterson goes you know maybe I
was wrong about that because he's a
smart rational guy and Ethan Klein had
that opportunity and could have gone
that middleof the road route where he
says y'all are crazy chill out I'm going
to talk to who I want to and believe
what I want to believe instead he told
people like us
like Jordan Peterson to f off your
bigots and racist and misogynists and he
hitched his wagon to people who are who
are calling him a Zionist Pig
celebrating Hamas I'm not saying P I'm
drawing the distinction and a dude who
quite literally said but babies are
settlers that's what Ethan Klein decided
to buy into congratulations buddy this
is what you this is what you you you
reap yourself my Wonder is like Ethan I
I feel like what's up dude uh your
intelligence is probably like a 12 like
it's not super high or like a little bit
it's like a above average intelligence
but's charismatic dude like he's he's
got Charisma but like the intellect
isn't like top level genius so I don't
I'm not drawn to like connecting with
him I like to talk with Scientists but
that doesn't mean that we leave people
like that behind like he's so
influential in society I want to help
him I think this is a really interesting
um internet fremes moment to have
because I think it's actually probably
what's going to happen when many
Progressive families assemble for
Thanksgiving right that they're going to
have to look at each other and instead
of it being like conservative Uncle
yells at you know Progressive NE isra
baby and it's going to be people who
think they're on the same side these
Generations that look apart and say like
but why are you saying this thing and I
can't and and like I think a lot of
people have this moment where saying
they'll have sort of extremist rhetoric
brought to them like this like the
justification of how and if and when you
should potentially harm children in this
conflict obviously answer is never uh
and have to confront these people they
think they have everything in common
with I think this is is a really
interesting moment of Reckoning and I
think because these are well-known
personalities you can see where the
bifurcation is but people are going to
experience this in their real lives very
soon right and I mean just this past
month alone I've seen Ethan Klein cry on
camera at least twice really yeah oh
yeah he get from the I saw that I was
crying oh yeah well and that's why I
think this is also why I feel bad for
man I don't think he's being as
calculated or at least not to this he
was he actually broke down in tears
talking about a video he saw of a a
Palestinian father clutching his dead
child
when he was talking to that got me too I
mean obviously it was terrible and like
I think he is someone who is ultimately
an empathetic person I don't think he's
evil and I think he is seeing the
horrors of this war but it you can't
deny that yeah he has he this is his bed
and he's he's been trying to capitalize
on these people who are now turning on
him because obviously they would
eventually it's the banality of evil
it's that when he deleted that Jordan
Peterson episode and then publicly
condemned Jordan Peterson I'm like yeah
that was the weakest yeah that that's
that that is when when you see that
photo of all the people doing the Roman
salute to Hitler and the one guy's
angrily like no that's the Defiance that
we respect the person who says I am not
going to just do it these people are
saying he was the guy doing the salute
he was just one of those other people
who was like I'm just going to do
whatever they tell me to do because I
don't want to I don't want to get fight
reling on his community for social
surrounded by evil surrounded by evil
people who would like listen if you if
you are someone who thinks that Israel
is taking it too far and they're killing
too many civilians I hear you if you're
who thinks Hamas went too far and they
started this on October 7th granted the
fight's been going on for Generations
then I hear you if you're going to sit
there and say but babies are settlers
like dude you you are way past that
point I have no idea there's that line
itself is insane even if after the fact
it says all right I get it babies
shouldn't die or whatever but like the
babies are settlers means he intended to
to get to that point morally yeah for
real no and it that's I've been kind of
blackpilled on Twitter because I've seen
people kind of argue also that well the
the Palestinian babies it's it's
basically just a future terrorist that's
being killed oh Absol it's nut I feel
just in general the past month I've seen
the worst of Humanity on social media on
both sides the people calling uh uh the
individual who said The only reason not
to Nuke Gaza is that the Fallout would
would impact Israelis Bethany Mandel
yeah insane that's like derangement that
is that is a degree of psychotic evil I
just but look always when everyone's
just like Israel this palestin that I'm
like I'm in the United States like I
don't know why were involved in that so
I'll leave it there the point is though
when it comes to left versus right in
this country and the and the fight we're
seeing in the breakdown of the left dude
Ethan could have a lot of people said
like why did he go into this leftist
camp where you can't be funny and you
have to be walking on eggshells he was
always like this edgy dude who made
offensive jokes he interviewed Jordan
Peterson he used to
say I I you can't even say him on
YouTube he used to say several racist
and homophobic slurs on his show
famously fairly long compil clip out
there of all the slurs that he's dropped
on his channel over the years and he
decided I better align with these people
who hate my guts congratulations they're
paying him I that's the thing he he
might be empathetic he might have
emotional attachment but this is like
his business now is to be saying the
right thing to the right people and I
can't
imagine exactly like there's there's
nothing he can do to change it and I
think in some ways it would be more
interesting to see a version of this
where there's principle there's
principle behind it saying like well you
know I believe this but you guys watch
be whatever or I have these certain
standards but he compromises himself and
I don't really follow his stuff that
intensely but he repeatedly compromises
what you think could be his value and
that means that ultimately he's he is to
be bought thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
800m and become a member over at
timcast.net